einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu heute live wir beschäftigen uns heute
abend mit der türkei mit der aktuellen
situation dort im land aber vor allem
und damit fangen wir an mit einem mann
der als renommierter und vielfach
ausgezeichneter türkischer journalist
seit einigen jahren in berlin
im exil lebt die rede ist von chongjin
da er selbst ist in der türkei vor
wenigen wochen in abwesenheit zu einer
langjährigen gefängnisstrafe verurteilt
worden
genaugenommen zu mehr als 27 jahren
wegen spionage und terror unterstützung
guten abend herr dünn da ich hoffe sie
können mich irren hallo rollstuhl so
krügel uplink dünner über ihre
verurteilung sprechen wir natürlich noch
zunächst aber sie haben einen spannenden
dokumentarfilm gedreht in diesem film
geht es um den putschversuch den
gescheiterten putschversuch 2016
warum war ihnen dieses thema wichtig
dass wichtig erstens hat einen sehr
persönlichen grund ich bin deswegen in
deutschland weilt das alles in der
türkei passiert ist in jener nacht ich
musste meinem land verlassen
ich habe meine ganze karriere meine
familie mein zuhause meine arbeit zurück
gelassen und wir nach deutschland
gekommen denn es wurde ein ganz neues
regime gegründet in der türkei nach dem
was in dieser nacht passiert ist wurde
erdogan zum einzigen machthaber in dem
land und deswegen ist es wichtig zu
wissen was in jener nacht in der türkei
passiert für mich persönlich ist hat
natürlich einen weiteren kunden
nicht nur ich sondern millionen von
menschen waren davon betroffen
das ganze schicksal des landes wurde
sich wurde ein anderes die türkei hat
sich von der demokratie entfernt das
regime wurde verbände das
parlamentarische regime wurde
abgeschafft es würde ein polizeistaat
gegründet und ein regime der repression
und auch deswegen ist es sehr wichtig
was in jener daten der türkei passiert
ist und natürlich ist es auch wichtig
dass die deutschen zuschauer verstehen
warum es in der türkei heute so aussieht
und das ist der hintergrund das ist halt
persönliche gesellschaftliche und
politische gründe warum ich dir den film
gemacht habe wir sprechen nachher auch
noch ausführlich über ihre aktuelle
situation in berlin auf ihren blick auch
auf die türkei sprechen aber auch mit
loop ort nach unserem korrespondenten
ihn ist dann wohl zunächst wollen wir
uns aber eben diesen film widmen der
heute im fernsehen ausgestrahlt wird auf
zdfinfo und viertel nach acht ist auch
in der zdf mediathek zu sehen und in
diesem film geht es um die ereignisse in
istanbul unter anderem im juli 2016 und
fest steht dass mit mehr als 350 toten
und weit über 2000 verletzten diese
ereignisse die türkei bis heute prägen
ein putschversuch erschütterter teil
wird 42 menschen auf der brücke das
leben kosten
ganz sicher das war ein wendepunkt
alles beginnt mit einer handvoll
soldaten
sie besetzen die briten
doch zivilisten stellen sich der was ihr
gemacht und gegen zehn stunden dauert
ein blutiger kampf
wenn man verstehen will was in dieser
nacht in der türkei vor sich ging
da muss man auch diese auf diese brücke
schauen was das für ein brutales gefühl
sein muss dass diese menschen in sich
getragen haben einfach bestialisch das
war für uns alle ein ereignis das in
unseren kühnsten träumen albträumen
nicht hätte stattfinden können
was dort vor sich ging spottet
eigentlich jeder beschreibung
es war es war grausam es war es war
dramatisch
es war schockierend irritierend
verstören
in den zehn stunden voller gewalt kann
abziehen sicherheitskameras auf einen
endlichen perspektiven jedes detail
festgehalten
erschreckende sehen die wir da jetzt
schon gesehen haben herr dünn da die
ereignisse auf dieser brücke liegen dann
zwischen mehr als vier jahre zurück wie
sehr bewegen sie diese bilder heute noch
wenn sie sehen dass ein schrecken ein
denn ich sage etwas persönliches als ich
in istanbul lebt lebt dich auf der
asiatischen seite denn sie wissen der
bosporus brücke verbindet die asiatische
mit der europäischen seite ich habe auf
der asiatischen seite gewohnt und auf
der europäischen seite gearbeitet
deswegen bin ich jedes mal zwischen
diesen beiden kontinenten hin und her
gefahren eben über diese brücke und
immer wenn es abend wurde kam ich von
europa nach asien zog wieder über diese
brücke das heißt das war mein täglicher
arbeit und nach hause weg es hat
natürlich auch eine symbolische brücke
symbolischer bedeutung denn diese brücke
verbindet die türkei mit europa dh wenn
diese brücke zu einer kampfzone wird
bombardiert wird zu einer zielscheibe
wird ist dass er eigentlich eine
bombardierung des türkischen bilde
europa das heißt nicht nur mein weg
sondern auch der weg der türkei nach
europa wurde bombardiert in jener nacht
sie leben seit 2016 in berlin können sie
sich noch erinnern wo und wie sie diese
ereignisse dort auf der bosporus brücke
erlebt haben
tokio sony ja ich kann mich sehr gut
erinnern
wahrscheinlich kann sich jeder der in
der türkei liegt sehr gut daran erinnern
das ist immer noch sehr frisch die wunde
blutet immer noch ich wurde zu drei
jahren gefängnis verurteilt ich war
wirklich hart und drei monate ich war
drei monaten gefängnis und dann bricht
er freigelassen
da kann ich wieder zu meiner arbeit
bei der jungen zeitung ab 5 uhr nachts
gearbeitet und dann wollte ich eine
sommerpause machen und ich bin nach
spanien gegangen ich wollte dort einen
kurzen urlaub machen und mich ein
bisschen erholen und ich arbeite gerade
an einem buch es kam ein anruf aus der
türkei er von der zeit und meine
kollegen haben gesagt die brücke wurde
gesperrt
und plötzlich war diese brücke ist von
jener nacht an für mich besonders
bedeutend ich hätte gar nicht gedacht
dass diese nacht meinen leben verändern
würde
ich möchte an dieser stelle noch einmal
ganz kurz unsere user auch dazu aufrufen
wie immer gerne mitzumachen fragen zu
stellen an herrn günther oder auch eure
kommentare zu schreiben wie immer bei
uns auch an die gewohnte adresse herr
dünner wie schwer war es für sie diesen
film zu realisieren sie sind ja nicht
mehr in der türkei waren ja auf hilfe
angewiesen von kollegen oder freunden 30
jahren mache ich dokumentarfilm die
menschen in der türkei nicht als
dokumentarfilm ecken vielberg vor allem
ich habe sehr viel gemacht sind aber ich
glaube das war der schwierigste virgen
film aus verschiedenen gründen erstens
zum ersten mal bin ich auf der
internationalen arena zum ersten mal
mache ich für ein publikum das ich nicht
kenne
in einer sprache die ich nicht spreche
eigenen film
das heißt dass hatte das war ein
ein zusätzliches problem denn ich und
meine art viel mehr zu machen was die cd
von mir erwartet was das deutsche
publikum von mir erwartet das waren
nicht immer das gleiche und wie sie
gesagt haben bin ich nicht in der türkei
ich brauche ich aus der türkei und daten
haben wir die kollegen aus von dem zdf
auch sehr viel geholfen
aber natürlich aus der türkei dann kam
noch die kurve oder krise hinzu das
heißt mit den menschen zu sprechen sie
zu interviewen die die hintergründe zu
recherchieren
das war besonders schwierig ein jahr
lang haben wir unter sehr schwierigen
bedeutungen gearbeitet aber er hat ein
sehr gutes archivmaterial sehr starke
der archivmaterial und deswegen glaube
ich dass der ganze schrecken der nacht
in diesem film gut zu sehen ist
ja ich habe den film schon gesehen ich
kann das bestätigen der schrecken der
wird allerdings transportiert man hat
szenen gesehen von unglaublicher gewalt
wie konnte es ihrer ansicht nach zu
dieser atmosphäre zu dieser brutalität
kommen wie die menschen miteinander
umgegangen sind zu jeder episode
das ist eine sehr gute frage wenn ich
zurückschaue habe ich immer noch
schwierigkeiten das zu verstehen und das
zu akzeptieren der menschen die sich
nicht gekannt habe ich noch nie begegnet
waren haben aufeinander geschossen dann
wurden menschen die nicht dieser ganze
strecken und wir mussten wirklich sehr
vieles herausschneiden aus menschlichen
gründen auch also nicht nur aus
journalistischen gründen sondern es war
so schrecklich dass wir es nicht zeigen
wollten zu sehen dass die menschen sich
zu etwas verwandelt können ist sehr
tragisch aber ich stellte sich vor
noch in diesem monat haben die menschen
das kapitol geströmt in den usa stellen
sich vor wie sie sich wohl gefühlt haben
menschen voller hass gehen aufeinander
los gehen auf institution los und dass
das sehr sehr gefährliches das hat zum
teil mit dem mädchen zu tun
wir erleben in einem propaganda krieg
zum teil hat das mit populistischen
machthabern zu tun das ist ihr
propaganda krieg das ist ihre
hasskampagne und zum teil hat das leider
damit zu tun dass die menschen sehr
leichtgläubig sind und sehr gleicht in
fallen gelockt werden können
das hat natürlich mit der bildung zu tun
mit den medien zu tun mit der
politischen bildung zu tun mit dem
politischen bewusstsein zu tun und so
lange das alles so aussieht gibt es die
gefahr immer doch sie haben die
staatsführung angesprochen also dass
staatspräsident erdogan auch seinen teil
dazu beigetragen hat dass sich die dinge
so entwickelt haben dass die gewalt so
eskalieren konnte das wird in ihrem film
eher dünn da auch noch mal sehr deutlich
lässt sich über facetime bei
nachrichtensenders cnn tisch zu schalten
und behauptet ja putschversuch
gleichzeitig besaß er natürlich auch die
unverfrorenheit seine eigenen
bürgerinnen und bürger auf die straßen
zu schicken zusagen widersetzt euch dem
panzern und somit ja auch das leben von
tausenden menschen zu gefährden das
leben von tausenden menschen aufs spiel
zu setzen um selbst an der macht zu
bleiben
[Musik]
um halb eins in der nacht verändert eine
nachricht die kräfteverhältnisse
die regierungspartei akp sendet eine
whatsapp auf die mobiltelefone ihrer
zehn millionen mitglieder
[Musik]
präsident erdogan telefoniert mit dem
präsidenten der religionsbehörde und
gibt anweisungen macht die moscheen auf
fordert die menschen auf die straße zu
gehen
120000 imame ein zu den moscheen
in 81 provinzen der türkei halt ihr ruf
durch die nacht
gleichzeitig und die menschen folgen
ja
ja damit gerade noch einmal die bilder
gesehen erdogan hat also das volk
aufgerufen ihn zu helfen ihnen zu hilfe
zu kommen er wusste dass es dabei viele
tote viele verletzte geben würde
trotzdem sind die massen ihnen gefolgt
warum ich hab mir den gründen in
unterschiedlichen gründen erstens ist
das ein punkt wo er keinen ausweg mehr
hatte ich habe auch ein buch über eltern
geschrieben ich habe verschiedene
dokumentarfilme über erdogan gemacht
sein reflex in diesen krisen momenten
haben wir wieder gesehen er versucht
immer einen pragmatischen weg zu finden
und eigentlich war das sehr schlau aus
der sicht des machthabers aber natürlich
sehr riskant für die bevölkerung gerd
die leute vor die panzer geschickt das
heißt er hat sich hinter das volk
versteckt das volk burgscheidungen
schutzschild das ist der hauptgrund für
den so viele menschen gestorben sind
menschen die nicht bewaffnet waren die
sich die schützen nicht wehren konnten
stand plötzlich den soldaten gegenüber
und älter und politische retten hing
damit zusammen dass heißt das volk hat
er gerettet aber leider konnte erdogan
das volk nicht retten aber warum haben
die menschen mitgemacht was haben die
sich davon versprochen
aus unterschiedlichen gründen es gibt ja
verschiedene gruppen und herzen menschen
glauben es gibt welche die fest an
eltern glauben und für eltern ihr leben
lassen würden das müssen wir zügig aus
welchen gründen auch immer sie so puls
also es gibt diese menschen da gibt es
eine andere gruppe
sie wissen ja dass in der türkei das
wird er mehrmals geputscht hat und diese
militärputsche haben die demokratie in
der türkei immer wieder aus der bahn
geworfen
und deswegen gibt es menschen die
tatsächlich die demokratie verteidigen
wollten gegen ein militärputsch
aber leider hat diese demokratie zu
schützen wollten ihnen schließlich ein
regime der repression geschenkt das
heißt sie wollten nicht aber sie haben
unterstützt die umwandlung der
demokratie in einem nicht demokratie es
gab wohl eine dritte gruppe das waren
milizen triemli ziehen und ihr mann
bewaffnet
erdogan hatte damit gerechnet dass mit
ihm etwas ähnliches passieren könnte und
deswegen hatte er
bewaffnete milizen organisiert und einer
von ihm oder sein berater in seinem
palast und viele von ihnen sind
pensionierte generäle und diese menschen
haben ihre waffen genommen und waren auf
der straße glauben wir
erdogan spricht in dem film von einem
geschenk gottes das ihm und seinen
unterstützern damit in die hände
gefallen sei mit diesem putsch wie ist
das zu verstehen dass sie vorher gezeigt
haben das erste an demnächst die
menschen auf die strasse gerufen hat auf
die straße angelegt mit eingeladen hat
das war eigentlich der der der
gipfelpunkt der ganzen nacht wir haben
versucht zu zeigen was davor passiert
ist und was danach passiert ist aber das
ist der moment in dem sich das schicksal
der nacht veränderte die landgemeinde
zusammen erarbeitet dass das war der
hintergrund vor allem haben wir da an
linie die deutschen zuschauer gedacht
das war eine zusammenarbeit zwischen
zwei islamistischen macht haben wir
haben die macht geteilt miteinander und
dann kam ein kampf zwischen den beiden
auf und in diesem putschversuch haben
sie gegeneinander gekämpft brutal
gekämpft und dann kommt der letzte akt
wo er da sagt dass ein geschenk gottes
denn dieser put versucht hat das gegeben
was er brauchte nämlich als einziger
herrscher das land beherrschen zu können
deswegen hat er die verfassung ändern
können hat die ganze unterstützung der
opposition in einer sogenannten
demokratischen kampagne zugesichert und
dann hat er seinen gegen putsch gemacht
er an dem ich den ausnahmezustand für
zwei jahre ausgerufen zwei jahre lang
hat der partie drehte regiert alles was
er wollte wurde zum gesetz er hat alle
seine widersacher beschuldigt den putsch
unterstützer haben er hat das
parlamentarische regime annulliert und
alle kräfte des staates an sich selbst
gebunden und deswegen war das eher ein
großes geschenk für ihn aufgrund der
tatsache dass er jetzt eigentlich
langfristig gesehen von diesem putsch
jedoch profitiert hat von diesen
putschversuch weiler das land ebenso
umbauen konnte in der folge wie er sich
das vorgestellt hat dass er also
vielleicht doch von diesen putsch schon
wusste ihn vielleicht sogar gebilligt
hat um dann losschlagen zu können
das ist die populärste frage in der
türkei seit fünf jahren suchen alle eine
antwort auf die frage wir haben das
natürlich auch getan
aber eines wissen wir das sehen wir auch
in dem film seit den mittagsstunden
dieses tages wusste der
nachrichtendienst dass dieser putsch
grund also eltern wusste es von den
mittagsstunden an aber wusste er dass
sogar früher und es gibt noch keine
verschwörungstheorien
die sagen er getan habe das selber
organisiert ich kann nicht sagen dass
wir da überhaupt welche konkreten
erkenntnisse hätten so als hätten wir
das natürlich auch gezeigt und mit der
öffentlichkeit geteilt das ist ein
bisschen verschwörungstheorie das heißt
dann hat das alles orchestriert und hat
selber organisiert sein wenn so viele
menschen gestorben sind in einer
nach dank ist das glaube ich ein
bisschen zu hoch gegriffen eine solche
verschwörungstheorie aber dass er seit
mittag seit der mittagszeit bescheid
wusste und dann irgendwie nichts machte
oder dass er nichts machen konnte dass
er die armee nicht dagegen mobilisieren
konnte und deswegen es in kauf genommen
hat dass es passiert ist
viele behaupten dass und wir haben auch
einige gründe das anzunehmen und
deswegen haben wir das in dem film auch
so gezeigt und der zuschauer soll selbst
eine entscheidung treffen
da es gibt auch von unseren usern einige
fragen an sie die werde ich gleich auch
noch an sie stellen zunächst aber wollen
wir ganz kurz auch sie noch mal
persönlich etwas genauer vorstellen wir
hatten schon angesprochen dass sie seit
einigen jahren im exil in berlin leben
das sie in abwesenheit in der türkei
verurteilt worden sind und mein kollege
jan frederik fischer bringt sie und ihre
arbeit unserem publikum nochmal etwas
näher
seit jahren gilt er in der türkei als
staatsfeind schaan dündar türkischer
journalist und dokumentarfilmer er ist
ehemaliger chefredakteur der
regierungskritischen zeitung cumhuriyet
und lebt seit 2016 im exil in berlin
ich zahle den preis dafür dass sich die
wahrheit erzählt habe dünn da geriet
2015 ins visier der türkischen politik
denn er hatte einen bericht über
illegale waffenlieferungen der regierung
an islamistische rebellen in syrien
veröffentlicht präsident erdogan tobte
und reichte höchstpersönlich klage ein
der vorwurf geheimnisverrat und spionage
diese person wird einen hohen preis
dafür zahlen ich werde nicht straflos
entkommen lassen denn da musste für drei
monate in u haft ehe das türkische
verfassungsgericht anordnete ihn auf
freien fuß zu setzen
doch die anschuldigung blieben 2016
verurteilten ihn die richter in istanbul
zu einer mehrjährigen haftstrafe und
dünner entging nur knapp einem attentat
er floh nach deutschland während seine
akte in der türkei offen blieb
ein neuer prozess wurde angestrengt und
sein vermögen beschlagnahmt vor wenigen
wochen dann das urteil mehr als 27 jahre
haft wegen spionage und unterstützung
einer terrororganisation
also ein hohes urteil gegen sie dazu die
tatsache dass ihr leben offensichtlich
bedroht ist wir haben gerade den
anschlagsversuch auf sie gesehen
vermissen sie trotzdem ihre heimat
natürlich dass meine ganze vergangenheit
meine familie ist da meine meine freunde
sind dort meine arbeit habe ich zurück
gelassen mein archiv habe ich zurück
gelassen meine bücher mein haus alles
natürlich vermisse ich es aber ich
vermisse bei allen eine befreiung türkei
ein land in dem präzision zu herrscht
dort zu leben und jeden moment um das
leben zu fürchten und nicht sprechen
können
das ist natürlich ein viel zu hoher
preis und dann ist für mich natürlich
meine freiheit wichtiger als mein land
das heißt wo ich frei leben kann wo ich
frei schreiben kann euch frei
produzieren kann ist für mich das land
wo ich sein möchte
wie ist ihre situation im exil die sind
ja offensichtlich noch sehr fleißig sie
haben unter anderem eben auch diesen
film fertiggestellt hilft ihnen das bei
der bewältigung der trauer vielleicht
auch der wut die sie ja empfinden müssen
angesichts ihrer situation wird die
politisch ist hat natürlich das ist eine
sehr wichtige feststellung
man ist ja weit entfernt man ist traurig
viele schwierigkeiten diese mit verboten
zu dem exil zu im exil zu leben und für
manche für manche menschen die ich kenne
sie zum teil auch persönlich ist es
psychisch sehr schwer sagte sicht aus
manche gehen wieder zurück manche
produziert überhaupt nicht
mehr manche haben psychische probleme
bei mir hat es dazu geführt dass ich
viel mehr produziere vielmehr arbeite
viel wütender geworden bin ich arbeite
viel mehr als ich dass jeder türkei
gemacht habe und dass nicht alle
journalisten treten
das ist meine verantwortung die spüre
ich muss auch für die menschen in der
türkei zum schweigen gebracht worden
sind sprechen
ein ganz einfaches beispiel kein
einziges fernsehen darf die film zeigen
den sie heute abend zeigt
denn jeder cent würde sofort geschlossen
das heißt so etwas sagen zu können so
etwas zeigen zu können ist unmöglich in
der türkei viele menschen haben das nie
gesehen und es ist eine verantwortung
für mich das auch den menschen in der
türkei zu zeigen nicht nur den mich in
der türkei sondern auch den menschen in
deutschland zu zeigen was in der türkei
passiert und passiert ist das ist meine
verantwortung deswegen muss ich doppelt
so viel arbeiten fragt über youtube ob
sie irgendwann herr dündar wieder in die
türkei zurückkehren werden also wie groß
ist ihre hoffnung dass die politische
lage sich so weit verändert in der
nächsten zeit dass sie zurückkehren
können ohne verhaftet zu werden sondern
er dann da ist kann ich nur zurückkehren
wenn ich es ins auge fasse und riskiere
mein leben lang im gefängnis zu sein
falls ich überhaupt überlegt überleben
heute kann ich nicht so aber in meinem
umfeld weiß man dass ich immer sehr
optimistisch bin und ich bewahre meine
hoffnung auch heute und diese dunkle
zeiten werden bald zu integrieren
seit 19 jahren an der macht und dass es
die unterstützung schwindet
wir sehen das in der wirtschaft wir
sehen das in den internationalen
beziehungen es gibt menschen die tasten
haben eigene partei gegründet haben und
wir sehen dass er in den
meinungsumfragen immer mehr verliert das
heißt er wird gehen aber wann und wie
ist wir noch nicht nur das wissen wir
nicht und deswegen ist eine psychologie
so dass ich jeden moment zurückkehren
könnte sie bewahren sich also ihren
optimismus wir haben noch zwei fragen
von hdx über youtube und auch von
wackers coach wir hoffentlich habe ich
das richtig gelesen über facebook die
wollen wissen warum haben sie sich
deutschland als asyl ort ausgesucht und
wie gefällt ihnen ihr leben in
deutschland
es gibt einige gründe dafür wie gesagt
da ich in spanien ich war im urlaub
und plötzlich war ich mit den europa und
konnte nicht zurück und musste mich
irgendwo niederlassen
es gab verschiedene alternativen die
beste bar deutschland denn die zeit hat
mir sofort ein angebot gemacht das ich
in der zeit schreiben kann und dann
haben reporter ohne grenzen und pen mich
sofort angesprochen und sie haben
unterstützung zugesagt hat die
journalistenorganisation korrektiv mir
eine zusammenarbeit angeboten
so mit mir zu arbeiten dokumentarfilm
mehr zu machen und da haben wir klar
geworden dass ich am besten in
deutschland arbeiten kann
natürlich gibt es ja viele menschen aus
der türkei hier ja das hat vor und
nachteile der vorteil ist dass sie
menschen haben die die gleiche sprache
sprechen wie sie es hat natürlich aber
auch nachteile also der geheimdienst ist
hier aktiv eltern unterstützer gibt es
hier aber hier kann ich die atmosphäre
in der türkei besser und besser atmen
dachte ich und die deutsche
öffentlichkeit interessiert sich der
starke die türkei und das ist ein großer
vorteil und deswegen habe ich berlin
vorgezogen ja wir hoffen dass wir mit
diesem gespräch heute abend auch dafür
gesorgt haben dass ich die
öffentlichkeit weiter für die situation
in der türkei interessiert weil es noch
mal auf ihren film hinschauen denn da
war das im exil lebender türkischer
journalist ganz lieben dank für den
besuch sozusagen hier bei uns heute
abend dankeschön für den vielen dank
also der film der kampf auf der bosporus
brücke die türkei und der gescheiterte
putschversuch so heißt er vollständig
über die ereignisse in jener nacht im
juli 2016
heute abend 20.15 auf zdfinfo und
jederzeit natürlich in der mediathek wir
haben nochmal einen ausschnitt aus
diesem film auch zu der frage wie es
nach dem putschversuch dann in der
türkei weiter ging wegen der morde auf
der bosporus brücke wurden 99 personen
zu hohen strafen verurteilt
es traf vor allem einfache soldaten und
kadetten der militärakademie
die regierung hatte beschlossen die
jenigen die inputs vereitelt hatten
nicht zur verantwortung zu ziehen
so blieben bisher auch die verschont die
budak die nicht gelöst haben
[Musik]
präsident erdogan hat neun monate nach
dem putsch versucht das parlamentarische
system abgeschafft
die verfassung wurde geändert exekutive
legislative judikative und die medien
wurden faktisch unter seine kontrolle
gestellt eltern ist jetzt
alleinherrscher
[Musik]
und wie zu beginn der sendung des
livestreams angekündigt schalten wir
jetzt nochmal nach istanbul zu unserem
korrespondenten lück wahl trotz der dort
steht und mit uns nochmal die aktuelle
lage in der türkei einordnet hinter dir
sieht man die bosporusbrücke die ja eine
tragische rolle hatte in dem film von
john günther im moment liegt sie
friedlich da aber inwieweit wirken die
ereignisse von 2016 noch nach heute in
der türkei
ja ich denke schon denn da hat das ja
sehr nachdrücklich beschrieben es war
schon eine dramatische und auch sehr
blutige mit vielen toten eine wende in
der innenpolitik hier in der türkei denn
es hat erdogan natürlich einen
zusätzlichen schub gegeben und er hat
danach ungebremst nun da das eben
beschrieben nämlich mit dekreten und
einer notverordnung hat er den
notzustand ausgerufen hat er dann
praktisch durchregieren können und die
vorbereitungen treffen können für den
umbau der republik wie er es vor hatte
und das die parlamentarische demokratie
ist insofern nicht abgeschafft man muss
das etwas vorsichtig sagen es gibt
weiterhin ein parlament das funktioniert
auch aber in diesem parlament hat seine
akp wenn keine mehrheit mit knapp unter
300 sitzen so doch die stärkste fraktion
und zusammen mit ihrem koalitionspartner
den ultra ultra nationalisten der mhp
eine komfortable mehrheit
und diese partei unter steht eben doch
praktisch dem diktat von erdogan es gibt
da kaum noch innere gegner und sicher
keine kritik also er kontrolliert die
partei damit kontrolliert er praktisch
auch das parlament und damit auch die
gesetzgebungsverfahren er kann also sehr
komfortabel regieren die exekutive also
die ausführung die ministerien sind alle
bei ihm im palast zusammen gezogen und
das wirklich traurige ist dass er auch
einen ziemlichen zugriff auf die
judikative also auf das rechtssystem in
der türkei hat und neuerdings die türkei
auch nicht mehr rücksicht auf urteile
des europäischen gerichtshofs für
menschenrechte in strassburg nimmt das
interessiert hier kaum noch jemanden der
straßburger gerichtshof hat ja bemängelt
dass ein mit 10 und industrieller wie
kavala immer noch im gefängnis sitzt
haft seit drei jahren jedes mal wenn ein
gericht den freispruch
am selben tag wird der mann wieder
verhaftet dann unter neuen
anschuldigungen der ehemalige parteichef
der kurdischen hd partei sitzt seit
jahren im gefängnis auch das wurde vom
gerichtshof gerügt dass alles bereitet
inzwischen an der türkischen regierung
ihr ab und dem staatspräsidenten
das sind schon beunruhigende
entwicklungen wir haben die frage für
hin ähnlich schon gestellt anschauen
denn da michael peter schreibt auf
facebook war das überhaupt einen putsch
oder war das eine inszenierung erdogan
sie ist da die einschätzung der
internationalen presse sozusagen kann
man da irgendwelche spekulationen
zitieren oder ist das alles im nebel
also ich kenne die einschätzung der
internationalen presse nicht aber ich
war hier in dieser putsch nacht und wir
haben die ergebnisse am nächsten tag
gesehen und auch gesehen was hier direkt
vor dem studio los war
es sind hier kampfhubschrauber bewaffnet
an unserem fenster vorbei gezogen direkt
hinter mir
es waren panzer auf den straßen das sind
wirklich dramatische szenen mit vielen
toten gewesen das parlament in ankara
ist aus der luft mit raketen beschossen
worden das war keine inszenierung das
war ein brutaler putschversuch zum glück
nur von einem kleinen teil der
streitkräfte
die frage die gender eben versucht hat
zu beantworten was wusste erdogan davon
und zu welchem zeitpunkt da ist viel
kaffeesatzleserei
fakt ist erdogan war in dieser nacht
selber nicht ganz sicher er war erst
sicher das sieht man auch in der doku
dann als er hier in istanbul mit seinem
flugzeug gelandet es bis dahin war
eigentlich alles in der schwebe nein ich
kann diesen verschwörungstheorien nichts
ab also dass das kann ich nicht
unterstreichen
im gegenteil meine einschätzung und die
vieler kolleginnen und kollegen hier ist
das war ein sehr brutaler und sehr
blutiger putschversuch der
glücklicherweise gescheitert ist das
muss man auch mal klar sagen auch wenn
die verhältnisse heute alles andere als
rosig sind in dieser türkei dann muss
man sich auch fragen was wäre denn
gewesen wenn die militärs übernommen
hätten das ist ja eine frage die zum
glück nicht beantwortet werden muss wir
haben ja gerade lange eben mit einem im
exil lebenden journalisten türkischen
journalisten gesprochen wie ist die
arbeit dort vor ort im moment für die
internationalen kollegen also eben auch
für das zdf zum beispiel ja das ist das
interessante die internationalen medien
haben relativ bewegungsfreiheit hier wir
bekommen nicht alles was wir wollen aber
das bekommen wir in anderen ländern auch
nicht also drehgenehmigungen
beispielsweise für alles aber es ist
nicht so dass man direkt auf unsere
berichterstattung zensur ausübt das ist
etwas ganz anders für die türkischen
kolleginnen und kollegen deren spielraum
wird ständig kleiner die repression
gegen türkische medien ist enorm
ein großteil der etablierten medien das
gilt für presse und fernsehen ist von
regierungsnahen unternehmen aufgekauft
die presse ist hier nie wirklich
unabhängig gewesen das ist immer eine
kommerzielle landschaft hier eine
presselandschaft und die unternehmen die
jetzt die großen outlets also die großen
medien besitzen sind alle in händen von
großen unternehmensgruppen die in der
einen oder anderen art in der einen oder
anderen weise auch von großen
staatsaufträgen profitieren und damit
sehr nahe bei der macht stehen und für
unabhängige journalisten ist kaum noch
platz die sind ausgewichen in
online-medien und diese online medien
denen versucht die regierung jetzt auch
den garaus zu machen es gibt da ein
neues gesetz gegen twitter facebook und
andere große soziale plattformen mit
mehr als einer million user in der
türkei
die müssen jetzt einen türkischen
vertreter benennen auf denen man dann
notfalls auch druck machen kann und sie
müssen auch bereit sein künftig inhalte
sofort abzuschalten wenn die regierung
das möchte tun sie das nicht gibt es
erst wie im fall twitter diese woche
geschehen ein verbot für werbung dann
dürfen keine türkischen firmen mehr bei
diesen sozialen plattformen werben
das ist nur der erste schritt der
nächste ist dann die bandbreite dieser
medien wird so weit reduziert bis am
ende nichts mehr übrig bleibt sprich bis
keine möglichkeiten mehr ist auf diese
plattformen zu kommen facebook hat
diesen schritt schon gemacht sie haben
einen türkischen vertreter benannt
twitter weigert sich und muss
wahrscheinlich dann irgendwann damit
rechnen dass sie vom netz genommen
werden hier also das alles klingt ja für
einmal normale deutsche ohren doch
einigermaßen befremdlich das ganze
system erdogan aber nichtsdestotrotz hat
er ja damit erfolgt in den letzten zwei
jahrzehnten gehabt wie ist das
eigentlich zu erklären warum hat er noch
diesen
kalt in der bevölkerung also das ist
eine komplizierte sache dazu muss man
die türkei wirklich seit langem kennen
es ist ja nicht so dass das jetzt ein
muster der demokratie war dieses land
vor der erdogan zeit
wir hatten hier john boehner hat es
angesprochen in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten immer wieder sehr blutige
und sehr brutale militärputsche das war
kein ort des friedens diese türkei und
die hälfte des landes die immer noch
oder mehr oder weniger hinter erdogan
steht das sind auch menschen die sich in
ihrer eigenen bewegungsfreiheit
jahrzehntelang von den militärs und den
republik gründern in ihren eigenen
freiheitsrechten bei einschränkt
eingeschränkt gefühlt haben nämlich die
sehr gläubigen sehr konservativen
insbesondere ländlichen
bevölkerungsanteile dieses landes die
dänen das kopftuch verboten wurde für
die frauen beispielsweise die sich in
ihren religiösen rechten eingeschränkt
fühlten
die haben mit erdogan jetzt das gefühl
dass sie auf der gewinnerstraße sind und
das ist auch ein teil der erklärung
warum trotz aller probleme hätte man
immer noch einen ziemlich beachtlichen
rückhalt in teilen der bevölkerung hat
insbesondere natürlich in denen die
seiner eigenen partei der akp nahe
stehen
allerdings muss man sagen das kann auch
bröckeln denn ein ein wirklich ein
schlüsselelement ist der erfolg der
wirtschaft die türkei hat jahrelang mit
wachstumsraten von über fünf prozent
gehabt bis zum knick 2018 und in den
letzten zwei jahren haben wir hier eine
echte achterbahnfahrt auch der währung
hat die enorm unter druck ist mehr als
30 prozent ihres wertes eingebüßt hat
die direktinvestitionen aus dem ausland
sind weg und jetzt kommt noch obendrauf
die korona krise die auch hier in der
türkei voll zuschlägt so dass wir nach
angaben der gewerkschaft wahrscheinlich
schon über zehn millionen arbeitslose
haben in diesem land das könnte echt
gefährlich werden für erdogan wenn er es
nicht mehr schafft die menschen zu
überzeugen dass im nächsten jahr mehr
geld in ihrem portemonnaie sein wird
dann könnte es eng für ihn werden
meine nächste frage lässt sich blenden
kombinieren mit der frage von suisse mal
bei youtube denken sie dass die türkei
irgendwann mal der eu
beitreten könnte oder anders noch einmal
gewendet inwieweit hat sich das land
unter erdogan von der eu entfernt und
ist da eine rückkehr in absehbarer zeit
denkbar
also ich habe eben die urteile des in
dem fall europarats des
menschenrechtsgerichtshofs angesprochen
es sieht im moment überhaupt nicht
danach aus als wenn da eine gemeinsame
plattform wäre für eine annäherung
zwischen der eu und der türkei der
türkische außenminister ist gerade heute
in brüssel gewesen hat versucht die
gespräche wieder in gang zu bringen aber
es gibt so viele probleme
das fängt bei den menschenrechten an bei
der unabhängigkeit der justiz und der
medien aber eben auch geopolitische
probleme es gibt diesen streit um erdgas
vorkommen mit griechenland einem
eu-mitglied direkt vor der haustür hier
im mittelmeer
es gibt die die das vorgehen der
türkischen streitkräfte gegen die
kurdische minderheit die an den
einmarsch in syrien alters sind riesige
konfliktpotenziale die überhaupt nicht
ausgeräumt sind mit der eu ich sehe aus
meiner warte wenig substanz für eine
annäherung man wird versuchen die
gespräche wieder in gang zu bringen aber
an eine schnelle annäherung zwischen der
eu und der türkei glaube ich jedenfalls
nicht
die einschätzungen von luckwald unser
korrespondent in istanbul ganz lieben
dank
ja und das war es mit unserem live
stream zum thema türkei beziehungsweise
zum film zum dokumentarfilm denen wir
euch auch noch mal ganz ja wirklich ans
herz legen wollen
der startet in wenigen minuten um
viertel nach acht auf zdfinfo als der
tipp von uns schaut euch das an oder
eben jederzeit auch in der zdf mediathek
wir hoffen euch hat dieses thema auf was
gebracht an erkenntnisgewinn euch allen
ein schönes wochenende und wir sagen
bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut
schatten